wow
thank you
good morning um
and that's it that's all i'm going to
say
my job is now my title is creative
technologist but it's kind of mixed with
creative technologist and front end lead
basically it means i get to evaluate
cool new technologies web technologies
and then tell our clients what we can
and can't do we try and come up with
creative ways
for them to do new stuff
and um
so i have to keep an eye on what's
coming
and one of the things that's coming that
most excites me is what i'm here to talk
about today which is web components
um
before i get into it properly just a
couple of little points point number one
what you see here is subject to change
but when i say that i mean just the
property names
and some of the values things like that
they're subject to change the concept of
web components is not going away this is
not some floated mooted technology that
may or may not happen this will happen
but possibly not exactly in the format
i'm going to show you
um the second point is there will be
code there will be lots of code i've
tried to keep it to a minimum but i
can't kind of avoid telling you about
new code stuff without showing you too
much code
and it's ironic that i've been asked to
speak here at css conf because css is
going to make up about 25 of what i'm
going to talk about
i have to get through the html and
javascript stuff to get to the good css
stuff at the end so all the explanation
of web components is just to get me to
where i want to be to talk about css
so i've said i'm here to talk about
web components but that's not exactly
the truth what i'm actually here to talk
to you about
is the secret of ultimate power
but you didn't know that when you bought
your tickets
i want to give you a very quick demo
this is the only time i'm going to break
out the browser window
so if you excuse me for this so what
we've got here
is a video element
and a video element you can see the
markup for it i hope that's large enough
for everybody to see it's just a video
element with nothing inside it
completely empty
but that video element has a play button
and it has a seek bar it has a timer and
it has a volume control it has so where
is all that stuff it's not here in the
markup
so we have to rely on the browser to
render that stuff for us but why should
that be the case why can't we make a
well we can make our own with javascript
but why can't we why do we have to use
javascript to to build this stuff from
scratch why can't we make our own stuff
and there's actually a little bit of a
secret in here
i've said it's empty
but
if i can find my cursor
and i can
enable this option here
and now go back into my markup
this is really hard doing this over my
shoulder
what's this inside
there's a document fragment wait that
there's a div
and there's lots more divs
and there's tons of divs and there's
input types
this video element is full of markup
but none of it's exposed to you
the browser makers up the browser
vendors are holding back this stuff from
you
back to my slides if i can
just go back to the wrong slide
okay so this thing is actually full of
markup which makes me think what the
fridge is going on
incorrect slide
all of this stuff the video element
the date picker
the progress bar all of this stuff
contains this markup which is not
available to you as developers the
browser makers have created it with html
css and javascript and just not exposed
it to you
this is the core of the concept that's
known as the shadow dom
you've probably heard of the shadow dom
that's essentially what it is it's
secret markup inside elements
it's rendered
but it's invisible in the dom
it's kind of like um
when you're on the when you're on the
metro and you're reading a copy of faust
by gerta but inside you've actually got
a copy of shades of grey
geheimes velangen i don't even want to
know what that means
um
so the shadow dom is shades of grey
there's your little tweetable thing for
today
i want to show you quickly how you can
make your own shadow dom
the first step is to create a shadow
root and one thing if you will just want
to bluff your way through talking about
the shadow dom just put the word shadow
in front of a bunch of stuff
you can talk about shadow root
shadow dom
shadow host uh shadow cat shadow wars
shadow anything just start talking about
shadow stuff and people go he knows
shadow dom
the shadow root is the new root inside
the element and it's very very easy to
create
you select an element and you say create
a shadow root
that's it what that's done is that's
created that new root inside that
element
and then you can
put some content inside there and append
it to your target element you've created
a shadow dom inside that element that's
how simple it is the markup um say you
have this markup
um
so you've got a div with an id of foo
and inside that is an h1 and then you
apply the rule i've just done which has
created a new shadow root with an h2
inside it the end result kind of looks
like this the h1 is no longer visible
it's been made invisible and the shadow
root takes preference the shadow dom is
what shows up just to break that out a
little bit
uh that's the shadow host which i
mentioned before which is the element
we've selected
and then the old
original dom markup was the h1 that's
the real dom as i call it
and then we created a new element inside
that relates to which is the shadow dom
ultimate power
creating elements inside elements which
aren't available to anybody else
you control how the page displays
ultimate power you've taken over the
browser vendor's role
shadow dom is
one attempt at solving a problem
and there are other
uh complementary technologies that aims
at solving the main problem which use
html and css as well
and the problem is this
say we've created a nice widget on our
website which does i don't know
something
whatever it does doesn't matter but
we've created this widget and we're
going to use it extensively across our
whole site
and we've created some css which is
going to style it blue
and then we go well this widget works so
well on this side i'm going to move over
to one of my other sites
special effects
the problem is on our other site
we have an existing
selector with higher specificity which
uses another color
it's overwritten
this thing and this is what prevents us
from having like genuine code
reusability today there are lots of ways
we've tried to stop this we've come up
with object oriented css
bem you know dry all this stuff
which tried to work around this problem
but the problem is still there this is
still a risk of code reusability
the solution lies in um
what's called encapsulation
and if you've used lots of other
object-oriented languages you'll
understand
encapsulation already
encapsulation
basically means
the thing has all it needs
everything it needs is contained within
itself
but it also means
nothing gets in and nothing gets out
so this encapsulation would allow us to
pick up a bunch of code and put it on
another website and not have to worry
about inheritance or conflicts anything
like that this is the problem
that web components are solving
we actually do have encapsulation in
html already
it looks like that
you could if you wanted to put all your
stuff inside a separate document and
include all the iframes and you have
some encapsulation
the problems with iframe well they're
too many to list but i'll try a few
extra network requests
multiple rendering contexts
and uh possible cross-origin uh resource
sharing conflicts
which make basically iframes just not a
great solution so the better
encapsulation
is web components
shadow dom is part of web components but
what are the whole thing um
one definition would probably be
they're a set or a suite of emerging
complementary standards aimed at making
reusable widgets
i would probably best define them as
the biggest change to web development
since xml http requests
they're genuinely going to be that
transformative
so the three core components of the web
components components of web components
parts i don't know the three bits of web
components ah shadow dom
templates
and custom elements
shadow dom we've already covered
so i will move on to talk about
templates
hands up if you've used mustache
handlebars
some kind of right most of you see
you're aware with how we do templating
at the moment it's probably done
something like this where you include a
script and you put stuff in it and you
can you can include variables and
holding and all that kind of stuff
that's a very very simple way of doing
it
so this is a really common pattern to do
this now which is why we have these
javascript libraries but what
web standards bodies are doing now is
trying not to create brand new stuff and
give it to you they're trying to look at
the stuff you do and make that native
so this is one of the first patterns
that is going to go native
so we've got this new
template element
and the template element just does this
you define it and then it has markup
inside it
so what's the advantage of doing that
instead of
using javascript
the markup inside this is inert
when the browser loads of the the page
with the template element inside it it
does nothing with the dark up that's
inside the template the template element
so if i had this i had an external
script being called and an image being
called
when i use the template element none of
that stuff gets loaded
the markup is completely inert it does
nothing
all it's there for is for you to pick up
and use elsewhere
if i go back to my original example i
showed a second ago i've got just an h2
element super simple barely worth making
a template for um
it's a little bit this this might be a
little bit complex for you but
try and try and stay with me so what's
inside this what's inside the template
element is known as
content
everyone's still with me on that
okay so what's in here is known as the
content
and we can get this content using the
new content object api
so we're going to clone that element in
there
we're going to get the content
and make a copy of it
and then we can
say choose another element that's on the
page and just append our content inside
it
so given markup like this we could then
clone what was in our template just
append it inside like that
really simple that's what template does
you're all used to it everybody knows it
the advantage is at this point the
markup becomes active so if you had
image if you had images if you had
external resources scripts and
everything when they get inserted into
the dom then they load
then they become active then you can
select them
so templates is just doing exactly what
we've already done they've just
standardized it and used the power of
the browser to make it a little better
this is what browsers do best is being
able to standardize the stuff that you
built on top of them and make them kind
of native give them core functionality
that they couldn't do otherwise
but if you've got templates in your page
as i showed there if they're in your
markup obviously they can only apply to
the same page there's got a kind of a
one-to-one relationship unless you're
using
ajax xml xml http request whatever but
by generally just like that they can
only be applied to the same page so what
we want to be able to do
is
make those templates more useful we want
to be able to share them across multiple
documents
um
which is where the import
relation type comes in so just by doing
this you can have the link in your head
you can say it's an import and you just
include
an html fragment
this will be done natively in the
browser so you'll be able to take all
the templates you've already made
and you'll be able to share them across
multiple files
from a one-to-one relationship you
suddenly go
like that
this is the reusability that we've been
talking about
this provides that reusability or makes
it much much easier that's what this
stuff's intended to do it's not intended
to do something brand new it's intended
to make stuff easier for you and native
so we talked about shadow dom we talked
about templates it's time to come on to
custom elements
so you've created stuff with a template
you might have appended a shadow dom
into it you've made code that's
encapsulated and reusable
but it still relies on you kind of um
marking up your content with class names
or something like that which just seems
a bit of a legacy kind of pattern
say we've created a special kind of new
bar called wunderbar
we would still have to use our
class names and everything to apply
those styles but wouldn't it be better
again if we could do that
natively if we could go for real 100
reusability just like we've seen shadow
dom gives us access to the elements
inside other elements
why can't we have access to the elements
themselves if we're doing a constant
repetitive markup pattern
why shouldn't we be able to make an
element that does that for us
and now we can
you just register
the element in the dom
you say okay we'll register this element
and we're going to call it vunder hyphen
bar
it has to be something hyphen something
because all html elements are a single
word so this by using by hyphenating it
just prevents conflicts with existing
and future html elements so we register
that
and now we have an element called
vunderbar which we can just place into
our document it gets rendered at dom
time
when when the dom is rendered it behaves
just like every other element on the
page
and inside that wonder bar
we have our shadow dom we have our
templates
so what we've got here
is fully encapsulated and reusable
elements
with shadow dom with templates
with custom elements
we can put stuff inside our elements and
we can just take that element put it
anywhere in our documents and it will
work and behave the same every single
place basically what this does as i've
heard quoted before is it kind of brings
semantics back to markup
rather than your page being covered in
divs or whatever or extended buttons
you can create your own elements
register them and they will work and
they will provide the exact same
functionality everywhere these are this
is what web components does
encapsulation reusability dead dead
simple
what i've shown you is like the tip of
the iceberg they do loads more you can
have per element apis you can define
your own it's exceptionally powerful but
the basic setup to get it up and running
the core concepts
are simple
and i think at the moment the big
problem with web components is just it's
probably just lacking a bit of
documentation it's probably lacking a
bit of detail it's hard to get your head
around at first but it's really really
super simple
so now that i've talked about what web
components are using html and javascript
i can get to the css
at last
it is css conf after all um
one brand new concept
that web components bring
and i say brand new is brand new to css
it's not brand new to web or computing
languages it's brand new to css
it's the concept of scope
now we're going to have to start
thinking about scope in our documents
which if you use javascript you're
already perfectly aware of
but just to give you a quick example
if i were to use an inline style element
like this
save the booing and the hissing until
afterwards if i were to use an inline
style element like this
css is all has the same scope currently
so no matter where i place that style in
my document
it's going to render every single p
across my whole document
there's no scope it doesn't get
contained just to where i put it in the
document the scope is totally global
but we want to be able to pick up
elements and drop them in other places
and we want to have that encapsulation
we want them to be
contained we want them to be
encapsulated
if we're putting css inside our
documents inside our widgets and
dropping them into websites that global
scope is going to leak styles back out
into the document it's going to have the
opposite problem with what we want
so the first attempt at
working around this is very very simple
you just add the scoped attribute to
your style
when that's there
css
has scope it's scoped to the parent of
wherever you've placed that style now
that p will only apply
here
um you don't actually need to do this if
you're using shadow dom
if i do this if i'm setting up a new
shadow root and i apply some css in
there i don't need to scope that
because shadow dom has its own scope the
shadow scope i told you about the shadow
x pattern right everything shadow
something shadow scope
and that's provided by something called
the shadow boundary
the shadow boundary is not as i first
suspected the name of the evil empire in
babylon 5.
a big love for babylon 5. that was good
that was big here in germany right
shadow boundary basically works like
this say we have our little reusable
widget
and
we apply some css and cs has just
applied directly to the widget right
that's non-controversial everybody knows
that
when we create a shadow dom it puts a
shadow boundary around that dom content
and the css is turned away
the way we can change that we can either
say actually i want this widget to
inherit all of the styles from my page
that's intentional
so we can just when we set it up we can
just say apply author styles
is true and that will just
let the css pass through the shadow
boundary by explicit permission
but there are times when we don't want
the whole of the css the style sheet to
be applied to our widget we just maybe
want some bits of it we want to expose
the widget to
the css we have to create kind of an api
for it a very low level api kind of
thing so we can just allow little bits
of css to apply to where we want them
and this is done through sudo elements
now you've probably used pseudoelements
before it's very very likely you have
like before after
or you can get even more complex ones
like i showed very briefly earlier an
example of a progress bar a css an html5
progress bar
and if you view the shadow dom for
that's the main element and then inside
that you get a div which is has this
pseudo element webkit progress bar
and then inside that there's a webkit
progress value so if i want to restyle
the progress bar
um webkit has exposed certain parts of
it to me
so i could change the color of that
progress bar from green to blue i could
do whatever i want with it because
they've actually exposed that to me
and there's a lot of these if you if you
search online you'll find a whole list
of these webkit only pseudo-elements and
firefox only pseudoelements
and with the shadow dom with us being
able to create our own reusable widgets
we want to be able to do the same as
well
these are being called parts
or the part attribute
and so when you set up your shadow dom
you've created a shadow root and then
you just add
an attribute to whatever content you put
inside you just say the part is and you
give it a name apes
in my case
and then you put that content inside
your target so when it's rendered you'll
get this you get your div and then you
get your document fragment which means
inside here is the shadow dom
and we say that's how it's rendered we
say part equals apes which means that's
exposed to the css
so by use of this
pseudoelement function
we can now apply styles directly to the
attributes we wanted to before
so we created our own kind of little css
api for this thing we've exposed certain
parts of it to styling
so i'm going to go back to scope for a
second
with css bringing scope that allows us
to do something that was previously not
really permitted in css
they're called custom properties
but really
they're variables but they're not full
variables
they have limits
this is how they're defined
first of all i give it some scope
i say this one applies to the whole body
of the document
and i'm defining a custom pro a custom
element a custom property called var
hyphen highlight that's the format you
have to use always var hyphen something
and then i give that a value
and then
in my code
i use the var function with the name
that was after that
so it's very very simple
variable like
syntax
it's not the full variable syntax people
have asked why not just use the string
you know everywhere else uses the string
and that's because these aren't fully
variables yet they're that's why they're
being they're not being called variables
they're being called custom properties
because you can't do anything with for
example the selector
you can't do anything with
the property
you can only change values
so that's why they're not being called
variables so much as custom properties
so this scope i talked about
so i've defined previously i've got my
thing set on the body and i'm going to
do it but then i can also just change it
to say
well inside only inside the foo element
then change what this
custom property does
again these are very simple just like if
you use sas or less you can send values
or arguments into these you can create
quite complex things but i'm showing you
the the absolute basics so this is the
reason why we have these now and i know
i've seen arguments again saying well we
can do variables in sas let's just have
that you can that's true the one thing
that browsers implementation brings to
the party is scope you can't do this
scope when using sas or ls
so the browser the one when they looked
at it and they said well actually as
we're creating scope now is a good time
for us to have custom properties we
couldn't do that before there was no
reason for us to do it um and as
everybody was totally correct you could
do it in sas unless there was no use for
it but css have found this opportunity
which is to provide scope which is why
they're being done natively
again you don't have to provide this if
you're creating a shadow dom
actually sorry i beg your pardon shadow
dom
this is the one exception where it will
inherit the css whether you uh permit it
or not that scope applies to everything
in the document so if you creating
something in the shadow dom you can
still use your custom properties there
that's perfectly valid
okay so i've just got a little time left
i'm going to talk about briefly
the future
or the possible future
this is stuff that's been mooted floated
may not happen not 100
because there are issues around it
but it's so
exciting and potentially terrifying in
what it allows us to do that i really
wanted to talk about it
these are called decorators
there's a new decorator element proposed
it's not implemented anywhere it's
proposed so it's a decorator element and
you give it an id
or some kind of unique identifier
and then you put a template inside it
and you can put whatever you like in
that template the other new thing we've
got here is this content element
and that's blank in here it's
totally blank so it says content
say we've got this markup here
which is from a conference i did
previously and neglected to update
say we've got this markup here and we
want to
uh what we can now do with it using
decorators
is using this new property
take the template which we defined on
the previous page
take that template
and apply it to this element
and the content of this element the h1
will now go where the content
tag was before
so this markup will become
using css
this markup
we're actually applying markup with css
which as i said is actually really
really clever
because you can use media queries to
actually fundamentally change the page
but also really terrifying
that could backfire badly
which is why it's not been implemented
yet but it's been floated and i think
it's a clever clever idea
but there are lots of issues around it
so that may not happen
so you're probably asking this is great
when's this stuff coming the thing is
this stuff is already
here in bits and pieces and quite often
prepped off
most of it is in chrome or canary
these guys are really pushing this stuff
hard it was their idea originally
especially chrome canary already has
shadow dom already has scope styles
already has some of custom elements
um
i think it's got uh the template element
is also in there
so there's it's all there and some of it
you have to enable through the flags but
it's it's kind of mostly there and
because of that opera which is based on
blink is also going to have this stuff
safari is following along slowly this
stuff was all implemented in webkit when
there was a when before chrome switched
to blink so some of it's still in webkit
but they're planning to take some bits
out
they're not too keen on the shadow dom
right now
but it is actually still there if you
download
uh
safari 6.1 or 7 it has that flag to hide
or enable the shadow dom so it's
implemented but they're removing the api
so you can't do anything with it
um and firefox or firefox nightly also
implements quite a lot of this stuff
they have uh
custom element registration they have uh
template element they have scoped styles
that's all in firefox again some of it
has to be enabled
but this is not something originally
when it was mooted it was like oh chrome
or just you know google are just
creating this stuff which no one's going
to use it's not the case this is a cross
browser like everybody's behind this
this is the future of web development
whether you like it or not it definitely
is coming
the best place to learn about this stuff
go to the polymer project
and again this stuff is unique because
the polymer project
is kind of a polyfill for all of this
stuff
but it's also
how
this stuff is getting
created
all of the feedback they're not the
browsers are not implementing much of
this stuff natively it's all being done
at kind of a low level api levels
they're create they're building this
polymer library to not only polyfill the
stuff but also to reflect the latest
standard and take in developer feedback
so the more you use this
the more developed the standard gets
this is being driven by the community
so it's a really really interesting
opportunity to get involved
go to
html5rocks.com they've got a bunch of
stuff on web components some really good
tutorials a guy called eric biedelman at
google who's driving this stuff
great explaining all of these things
um follow him on google plus he writes
about a lot there
mozilla have created this pattern
library called brick which is a series
of
custom elements that you can just take
and use straight away as i said mozilla
are fully behind this
and there's a website called
customers.io which is a community-based
repository of custom elements that so
you can just take the library take the
element drop it in your page and this
stuff just works
in conclusion
what's that doing there in conclusion
web components provide reusability and
encapsulation
and scope is coming to css
thank you
thanks
you